totally unrelated segment because he's
got to talk about it man
uh my friends
is am i going to get in trouble if i say
the end is nigh no i don't think so the
end is nigh
there we go
u.s economy is growing quickly but
flashing an inflation warning sign
prices of goods we use every day are
rising at their fastest pace in three
years with coffee up eight percent bred
up 11
and gasoline up 22 we got a chart here
from daily mail this is amazing bacon
11 increase unacceptable i was story
about baking bread is up 11. chicken is
up 10 coffee eight eggs seven milk's
only up three percent gas is up twenty
percent corn is up forty four percent
yep when corn goes up everything goes up
you know why feed it we feed cows and
chickens and all the animals corn these
factory farms
cotton is up 10 appliances 15 furniture
3.5
dude you know what really bothers me
all last year i'm like we're we're
borrowing money for ourselves these
massive you know debt relief packages
the dollar is gonna tank did i go and
buy bitcoin
no
i did
[Laughter]
i did buy in november it takes eight
months to catch up we talked about that
last year it's like it's gonna be eight
months before inflation starts to rock
people yep and so i'm just i'm so i'm
i'm
this is the story of life for probably
everybody
i bought i i was the guy who always
jokes about the story like in 2011 i
almost bought thousands of bitcoin at 70
cents a piece and i didn't ha ha and
then it was at like 200 and tell the
same story and then it said a thousand
dollars to tell the same story then it
said five thousand
and eventually it's just like maybe at
some point i should just buy a lot of
bitcoin i don't
i don't i just and so so now a year ago
i'm like the inflation is gonna hit you
just you gotta understand lumber is up
between 250 and 600 percent
steel is skyrocketing the price of
everything is going up
hyperinflation is a serious fear and
we've got numerous reports the market is
there's a market crash looming so some
investors are saying that they're
they're they're uh bearish and they
think a 30 hit to the market this year
so
i hear all this i report on all of this
i watch the the ridiculous money
printing
bitcoin but then you did a little bit
you could have went deep i could have
went deep i could have been like
i'm reporting on all this stuff and
paying attention i should buy a lot and
then so what happens is in november
bitcoin's at fifteen thousand dollars
and i'm like wow that's so incredibly
high you know so i'll maybe i'll just
buy a little bit and then it goes up to
forty thousand dollars like wow that's
so incredibly high i'm not going to buy
anymore
never never said sixty thousand dollars
you can always print more money and make
the value of everything else go up
that's just happening yeah so
there's gonna be a big ripple effect and
it's gonna get better when you were
given these numbers nine percent eight
percent is that in the last 12 months
right now like are they up 10 from last
year at this time uh they don't say just
says
from labor statistics
uh okay from last year probably yeah
yeah i was looking up the inflation rate
and they're like the inflation rate is
1.7
and i think that's just the rate that
the federal reserve decides to charge
interest at on their loans to the banks
so that's not the actual inflation
actual inflation is very different than
inflation rate the rate is kept
artificially low because they're like
we're only gonna but actual inflation as
you can see the cost of of goods are
like beginning to skyrocket so i'm
working you know my office is downstairs
from the studio one day a couple months
ago ian knocks on the door and he's like
yo dude
i just bought a bunch of doge
and i was like yeah whatever and you and
and ian's like it's like five cents and
i was like yeah whatever it's like i
think it's gonna go up dude i'm worried
because like oh no you bought it like
nine cents right since yeah then it went
down and you're like but i'm gonna hold
it and see what happens
and then i'm like i'm like ian get out
of here i don't care about your meme
coin doge whatever nonsense i'm not
buying
and now it's at 60 cents
or
60 so 57 at the beginning of the show
what was it it hit 16. earlier today
yeah you got the power of elon musk and
starship martial
well so
i think there's two a couple things here
people are trying to find a place to put
their dollars because you got buying
power right now at the dollar and we're
watching it go down
think about let me do some uh simple uh
meth analogy for all y'all
we have here on this daily mail thing it
says chicken up 10
that means if you want to buy a chicken
you have to work 10
more than you did last year right so
that means if a chicken normally takes
one hour of labor tack on another six
minutes of that work you got to do
so that that stuff adds up now you're
looking at chicken bread bacon
everything you've got to work 10 to 20
more corn is 44
when the when that ripples through the
chicken because they feed chicken and
cows and all this factory farm corn and
even fish
the price of everything is going to go
up because these factory farms are like
we need corn but corn is really
expensive
okay raise the price on everything else
you're gonna you're gonna be
making like somebody who makes 15 bucks
an hour right now could like buy three
chickens
and then now it's up ten percent now you
can only buy you know two and a half or
something you know i mean i'm not doing
actual math the point is
all of these numbers mean you have to
work longer to get the same thing
so people are trying to find a place to
take your existing buying power let's
say for every hour you work you can buy
a chicken
so they're like okay all the currency i
get from this work if i put it into
bitcoin or something then when the hyper
inflation hits i'll still be able to buy
the same amount of chicken
but if you hold the dollars you won't be
able to that was my thought last year
around may june july is when i really
started going into crypto hard when i
saw the big printing that they did last
year that two four trillion printing oh
yeah and i it wasn't that i wanted to
buy bitcoin it was that i wanted to park
my money somewhere that wasn't going to
get deflated so i have a i have a
question you might think i'm dumb for
asking this but genuine question about
um cryptocurrencies when you put dollars
us dollars into cryptocurrency
how do you get it out in a way that's
not us dollars
like what like you're parking your money
there to what end how are you imagining
that so so there's minds.comminds.com
and they have tokens
so these are erc20 tokens they're
they're they're built off of ethereum
right is that that's how it works yeah
the erc20 blockchain is what they ride
on okay they're it's different than the
ethereum token it's they're different
the blockchain's different right
so you can have a a bitcoin or whatever
it's basically like me saying here ian
i'll give you this for a dollar and then
ian takes the bottle of water and gives
me a dollar and then ian trades the
bottle of water for a can of pepsi okay
that's all it is okay so just a
different form so cryptocurrency is
basically just a uh non-copyable digital
asset you can trade for whatever you
want to trade it for the oakland a's
will let you buy tickets with dogecoin
oh cool
wow
hold on bitcoin is like gold and
dogecoin becomes like cash sure oh
no not like it's over like cash litecoin
is like silver printing out little
things you can carry around rfc no
dogecoin app and you just you scan we're
pretty much at the whole scan the
checkbook checkout line anyway so yeah
so think about it i think i think
dogecoin will probably in my opinion
first let me just say i do have i bought
a bunch i bought a bunch i wish i bought
substantially more i did buy a
ridiculous amount like seven years ago
when it came out as a joke
i i have no idea where it is and it's a
lot
yeah it's like an old computer and i was
like yeah because it was like point zero
zero what was it like zero zero zero one
percent or something i got something so
angry so when i saw it i couldn't bring
myself i i had i hate hate refused it
but what people need to realize too
when you see your crypto portfolio going
up and you're cheering that's actually
scary because your buying power isn't
going up i mean to to a certain degree
it is obviously like a 10 increase in
chicken but
1 000 increase in in you know doge or
whatever or like uh
what is it what is ethereum up like 300
percent
also it's like 3 200 now yeah it was
yeah so 1700 a couple weeks ago well
like when we had bill on the show last
time bill ottman it was a thousand bucks
yeah for ethereum now it's at 3 200. so
yeah the gain in crypto is better than
is higher than the inflation for most of
these goods
but would i think
there was an article i read they said if
you had 10 in lumber in november that
would cost you 60 today wow and i'm like
that's that's comparable to like bitcoin
wow wood yeah building materials
it's going to get harder and harder to
buy stuff and there's just tons of
shortages furniture is not worth more
you said that's maybe i wonder a lot of
these things are being artificially kept
turning up 3.5 3.5 only oh
this is going to get scary man um i
don't think people realize that uh what
will first happen
all the goods are going to get more
expensive construction materials are
going to be more expensive labor won't
get as expensive as quickly
after the cost of food goes up then
people are going to be like i need more
money right but businesses can't just
snap their fingers and give more money i
mean the leftists think they can but
they can't now i'm sure starbucks and
walmart can
sort of but small businesses can't do
that they small business is gonna be
like dude we're a coffee shop coffee's
up eight percent
i can't not we're already losing money
now i can't just give you a raise we're
already losing eight percent off the
coffee but my groceries went up eight
percent so you got to spend 16 to take
care of me now so then they have to
increase the price of coffee by 16
percent or we do trade with honduras
yeah there you go that's where our
coffee's solved
that's a good solution yeah yeah yeah i
think i think dogecoin is gonna
skyrocket and people have done the math
dogecoin isn't as like
i guess finite as bitcoin yeah what's up
with that so i don't know the full
numbers but i was reading something
where they said like dogecoin is gonna
print a ridiculous amount as opposed to
bitcoin's what 21 million yeah something
like that so that means there's going to
be a massive supply of dogecoin for
trade so dogecoin could theoretically
become like cash oh boy i was hearing
that dogecoin automatically deflates
every year there like some of it is like
splits or something from the circulation
which is a very interesting concept
where does it go i didn't i was getting
removed i don't know to be honest i just
read it like nah you're like here's my
account i have 100 doge and it's gone
why oh no like that's how that works i
don't know maybe it's in the mining when
you trade make trades they slowly pull
it out of the circulation or something
i mean you mean like the blockchains
having or not mining rather but gas fees
and stuff gas fees sometimes
coin's not if you're using this is not
on the erc20 block channel
dogecoin is a is a like a uh i don't
know it's not a fork but it's a clone of
bitcoin
yeah so this was made a long time ago
interesting concept though i used to
think what if we made a money that lost
value if you didn't spend it so that
we're incentivized to keep it
circulating you mean like us dollars
yeah but not so it's not like this not
like this never like that what do you
mean it's exactly what it is just more
like if you and i each had a thousand
dollars and i sat on it and you spent
yours and then made a thousand more
you'd still have a thousand but i have
990 at the end of the day that's
basically what the dollars do so they
want me to move it well what's happening
now is they're getting interest for
holding it i don't want to i want to
dis-incentivize people for holding it
that's that's that's what they do well
they give you interest they incentivize
you to hold your money now they want you
to just get richer for having money but
you're not beating inflation
like so you might not need inflation if
you slowly deflated the currency over
time deflated yeah if you slowly if
people aren't spending and it slowly
depreciates the value of the currency do
you mean inflate the wait what do you
mean well like so if you have a thousand
dollars in the bank and a day goes by
and you don't spend it you may lose a
percentage of that back to the that's
called they do that's called negative
interest rates and then so that would
incentivize people to keep the money
flowing yeah they do that sometimes when
the market's like really really bad
they'll do negative interest rates where
they're like if you keep the money in
the bank you'll lose but rather than do
it to everyone at once just have that be
built into the currency's function
man i'm i'm i wonder what's going to
happen with this doe stuff man it's
going to be worth it
elon musk is going to go on saturday
night live
and he's going to be like dogecoin and
then it's going to hit it if he goes on
with the dog yes he's got to go on the
toshiba yeah yeah maybe maybe so i think
the reason does coin is skyrocketing
right now is because
elon musk is going to go on and they
think he's going to do some doge skit
it's going to cause the price to
skyrocket that's funny yeah i i'll tell
you this um i'm never going to sell the
doge
hold it dude it's funnier to have
and i don't have enough to actually
matter
like i wish
in 2014 i spent two grand on doge i
think you tweeted out today there are
doge millionaires i mean that's kind of
obvious yeah but like there are probably
a lot of them dude when doge went to
like three or four cents i'm sure some
person was like i'm gonna buy a
ridiculous amount why not
in the past
i had purchased like tens of thousands
of just garbage coins that were like
essay 20 tokens that were worth like an
eighth of a cent red coin i don't know
just like weird random trash and i was
like hey maybe this will be the one that
you know and like i just never cared and
i forgot my friend a bottle i did have a
bunch of doge and i just it was
worthless like this is what happens back
in the day you have like you know 50
bucks worth and you're like i don't care
whatever and back then i mean 50 bucks
would end up being like you know i don't
know what like 100 grand or something
today in dogecoin
some ridiculous amount
well
look i don't know what's going to happen
with all this inflation stuff they're
trying to act like it's a good thing it
means wages will go up
before depression yeah if you look at
the history of the great depression they
were the week before the stock market
collapse they were talking how great it
was what a good time to buy stocks it
was right take out loans and buy stocks
on loans
post your earnings is collateral yeah
this is so annoying because the economy
has way too many moving parts to say
something is a positive you have no way
of knowing if it's going to affect 15
other different things negatively yes
they can lie too they can blatantly tell
you it's a safe good time for your
investments and not get on the hook for
it
crashes it's crazy
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you